e
as pessoas vão falar comigo eu fico
interrompendo eu isso já
como eu ia dizendo tu já
viste os tipos de espirros téspios
surpresa aqueles que você não sabia que
ia catar lançou um catálogo você não
tava sentindo nada vocês viram mais um
catarro Parece que saiu da medula você
faz isso aqui ó ó
E aí
agora esse negócio verde aqui na mão
parece minha mãe ganhou o meu primo rico
sem fio de velho meu amigo espirro de
velho se você acha que você espirrar ou
espiritual pôde velho quebra todas as
barreiras do Sol sem fazer a prestar
atenção não foi de vocês espirrando é a
E aí
eu acho que ele vai me escutar o espirro
dele ele não bota fé que espirrou é
quando vem é isso aí poder escutar tem
que esperar muito alto e tem gente que
preparou isso viu porque tem gente tem
que preparar o escrivão é
oi oi